hello and welcome to this video playing
am Krupa okay cool I don't think he has
a name in there I store my charlie cop
I'm sorry I didn't didn't really have
this on the radar so I'm trying my
bishop survival idea that I recently
started to experiment with and just try
to battle the English opening by simple
development just play it like in the
Italian game okay some wants to go quick
before here Jim not much not much that I
can do about it to be honest yeah b5 is
coming real quickly here I don't know do
I want to take mm maybe yeah you know
I'm completely undecided what makes
sense a one but not maybe mph come on
okay so he wants to take this I guess
hmm Joe not happy about that
you still probably should just take on a
six and maybe trade on be eight and yeah
okay maybe just D for whites position is
certainly very solid very healthy okay
if I go Bishop is six there's some
create for I guess hmm okay i don't mind
c5 so much I wonder FC six is an idea
for me I mean at Bishop hair looks
really wrong maybe Bishop d7 and Bishop
to see 60 it also looks wrong okay if he
calls queen bee three I still a push
myself ok I think I'm going to try to
shoot for some counter play him it looks
very caveman style but he pretended he
has pieces on the queenside and
potentially even some more I mean he
wants to play Queen yeah something like
that and the drawback of such a move is
that the Queen doesn't defend at all so
let's see if i can get this going
what is my plan taking on g3 and some
night gee 496 something like that okay
that's I use a decision going to take
and now i have night f5 as well and the
apprentices this is something that I
don't mind I think attacking d4 and
bring the night into closer and closer
proximity to the king okay Queen have
six or something is this the idea
yeah that's not really threatening watch
95 is coming then but okay it should be
at least somewhat irritating for g5
maybe between g5 and between h5 this
this assistance is a threat okay yeah I
guess Prince you fire for attending
maybe night to f2 and taking on f2 it's
very close to working maybe it is
working actually end queen age 5 this is
also around the corner 95 would be
extremely cold blooded maybe
where the queen is on a form it's not
assisting in the defense at all
I think the most serious idea have a
screen age 59 f 2 isn't a threat at all
at least yeah maybe it is actually like
Knight takes King takes Queen III check
kingi 2nite XD form and threatens on a
three and knight takes Bishop takes it's
definitely very dangerous Jen maybe it's
not playing at all Quintus is 6 this is
probably defending against this night f2
business and it looks at this at the
light squares are interesting hmm
okay an interesting idea it's also night
every three or the other night do we
know every three actually attacking the
rook okay i also have Queen to h5 she
will take take Quincy 7mm edge for not
sure how good datos okay Queen and Queen
is on c6 I have this night every three
but it doesn't doesn't threaten much
time morning yeah i wonder if i should
play night have to come on let's do it
it's um it's so tough on my rear many
possible a chance so what I want you to
do something direct him and night takes
deform it really is it's very aggressive
he has not yet screenie for actually I
didn't see that move he has Queenie for
ya damn maybe Bishop takes huh Bishop
takes Knight takes Queen takes you three
I don't know I can't tell ya this is
just too complicated for me Knight takes
Knight takes Queen e4 it's probably
possible I takes Knight takes Queen e4
and you should make three it takes with
a rogue okay and not not not a big
choice now
ok this one now I can actually just play
this position I don't need you know
don't need to check matin materialize
I'm ok look n two pawns like forfeits
yeah and that is the time mmm very tough
game I'm definitely trouble on the
queenside here but I had some counter
play it's hard to say maybe I was worse
when b5 him this is all looking very
normal and yes this this yeah my Korean
side looks funny but it's it's almost a
given that he has to play some pieces to
the queenside after which my attack
could become dangerous so aged 5 and
create for a very logical move the stock
fish wants to play f4 it's an
interesting interesting idea now let
move would have shocked me really
ideas to take on tv5 and possible 95
interesting this is the engine slide
slide advantage to white wow it looks it
looks very interesting probably good for
white and this is what the Angelus is
giving a good and nothing i mean i have
no idea what this pollution but ok i
think what he did was very humid air and
queen 84 no H 4 M and K will be one and
it was attacked and now I start this
counter play I think I don't think I
mean I'm don't think I'm a bad shape i
think it's a clear cover to play ok went
back there Queen d1 was also possible
certainly yeah now just try to look
aggressive with nijah for even though
it's not so clear what it threatens yeah
this is probably too lame what does the
engine give 94 again quite logical
preventing Queen g5 Queen f6 business
yeah between you seven something like
this and it gives equal now it's it's a
very tough position c5 maybe that's a
crazy line and given by the computer
here what what one of those what the
beep lines I know it just white a clear
advantage so I was really wondering why
I should tend to her okay oh because I
should go here uh-huh this I know I have
a counter play here computer gives this
probably leading to some kind of draw
hmm ok ok a very sharp ok now now things
get dangerous and ok I took them which
just seems to be okay according to the
engine but it wants to do this this ok
90 x and then smash on f 2 with a clear
advantage yeah that just making some
sense really ok and here after King
takes I'm fine with the line in the game
I think but we should see one that would
have been a cooler ok when I like a
check and go back because it cannot take
the light right back to the eighth chaos
q innate and sorry chaotic ok so just
happened and now you should take this
good yeah yeah 90 exosome doesn't help I
thought we knew forward we should see
one is even stronger and now we are
Knight takes Knight takes is good text
tons of stuff everything is hanging here
this is hanging so you took with the
rope now it takes 24 yeah and now I can
just go to the ending here where I'm
slightly better maybe here slightly look
into pawns huh it depends a bit on I get
this and keep those pawns okie it wasn't
so relevant because he lost some time
but position wise it's a tough call i
think jim i know if black should win
it's clearly better for him but not
clear ok thanks for watching